video arcola a corner in all my best
clients yes and yes like scored 20 out
of 23 that's a lot 18 wins one loss four
draws that line is extremely dry if I go
d5 okay this is a little bit on the
diocese side but it is it's interesting
okay doesn't want your damage my pawn
structure interesting so i can check
here after which she basically has to
give up canceling okay it's not the end
of the world quite clearly but
I'm hesitating because of the move
Bishop 2d aid and it's kind of
interesting ideas to take and then
Bishop a5 that activates the bishop and
puts it on some sensitive squares yeah
yeah like you see 796 and so on not
entirely sure it is good that could be a
good idea White King doesn't have any
any really safe place to go Wow just
goes right in the middle of the board
Wow okay so yeah like 95 b5 I said
stable maybe it is but hmm might be for
my don't see an idea wow whoa what are
you doing here I don't get that so
weakening his weakening his own position
here
hmm you will be five comes into
consideration here okay I brute all that
and what does he doing against it so
yeah you up chicks as possible but ok
this is this is the move that I wanted
to play you should G for now is really
annoying hear what what's going on g5
so I can check your man tears to go to
f1
it's not that convincing actually yet
okay i'm doing this first and then work
out the details so i would like to go 95
to d3 yet not so easy to do now we don't
care i get there probably like this even
though i have not really looked at
Bishop takes before I just hoping that
that there's something did not calculate
that move I don't have like I don't have
the capture check here and then 93 it
doesn't quite work unfortunately maybe
this move friends 92 and all kinds of
things he takes it time money yep she
takes root g one let's move the miracle
chest but it works so for me Luke checks
we should know then loop 25 was the idea
now a swoop t1 ideas just request aid
next which I'm not sure this work to be
honest stupid yeah I am ok it takes that
rogue f2e to look F to should should be
good I didn't have much time there to
figure it out Luke g2 Bush of 83 it
should definitely work you have rookie
tube g2 checks out and cannot take on a
five hmm I don't see a defense split
remarkable but I don't see one may be
soo ro G tool something OOP takes f 2 is
annoying to say the least
don't don't see a move okay that was a
good move action very good move and
bishop doesn't have squares of the thing
yeah how he did find that move great and
I have no square here friggin okay but I
really lose the second game against this
clam probably yes so going to try Jeff
Jeff it's probably made somewhere I know
he took that the Pacific you get a male
ah man wasn't that winning for black
that's it isn't there I really thought
Luke g3 is the only move I didn't see
that I really thought he has no move
there and that's a bit of a shame
because I that must have been excellent
for black I don't believe this you have
one bit g4s a crazy move but I didn't
didn't really refute it it seems ok so
maybe this was a bit too much then just
rookie area I mean it's just weaken its
own own position to sg4 who create
it was a bit too much even though this
sure looks good Jim yeah yeah I was just
like playing for that there must be
something and because it looks so bad
for white but since there wasn't seems
there wasn't here this group g1 Luke g1
assisted defense when you achieve one is
also important that's the only way to
save the night he needs those kind of
tactics yeah this was this was maybe
better and suggest I'm still so active
but I shouldn't have gone for the wall
complications I mean simple moves would
have been completely sufficient probably
okay yeah just look heh and what is all
this I mean I'm threatening 95 now and
if he takes Bishop takes I just get the
same attack as in the game just I'm not
material down he has this bad night and
so on yeah I just play simple chance
it's what it is okay thanks